statt denn ein natel weiß ich in die 1
[Musik]
das leben klar herzlich willkommen meine
liebe zuschauer hier zu einem neuen blog
auf einem kanal
ich will so gut drauf hat ja gerade
seine lieblings youtube
du bist du auch schon gespannt auf katja
songs nein es ist schon 15 12 der songs
draußen muss ich geh jetzt drauf leute
ich bin gespannt also wir sehen hier
schon katja glaser wird es direkt
eingeblendet einem track ist vor 45
minuten raus gekommen und hat gerade
200.000 aufrufe also das willst du auf
jeden fall schon mal eine gute marke
katja glaser witz ist allgemein relativ
gute marke es war nicht so repräsentativ
aber sie verkauft sich gut und das ist
denke ich auch der grund warum bei ihrem
dreh für dieses musikvideo polizisten
die aufnahmen gestört haben weil sie
dachten dass da ein sextape gedreht wird
wurde allerdings auch jedoch kein als
text etwas entgegen wir auf irgend einer
unseriösen plattform hochgeladen wird
sondern das ist halt die neues lied es
heißt sex tape und ich würde sagen wir
schauen mal direkt rein
[Musik]
also man kann direkt sagen der beat ist
viel viel viel viel besser als bei dicke
lippen und bei doc nicht mal ganz
ehrlich freunde
loki war es ein bisschen naja jedoch hat
sie dann bei die klippen echt einiges
besser gemacht und ich habe seine
reaktion auf den klippen schon gesagt
hey katja du hast potenzial das ist echt
vernünftig eigentlich allerdings würde
ich sagen ich klicke ich hier mal wieder
weiter auf play
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht warum sie auf einer
es steht wahrscheinlich weil sie auf dem
strassenstrich geht allerdings mit ok
sie ist da sehr sehr gut direkt rein
gegangen
find ich gut man merkt das ist wirklich
professionell die letzten songs und hat
alle die sich jetzt und in den
kommentaren beschweren
luca was redest du die ganze zeit
dazwischen das ist halt meine reaktion
wenn ihr euch das lied ohne meine
kommentare dazu anschauen möchte dann
geht auf katjas kanal aber ich reagiere
halt da drauf und ich würde sagen wir
schauen jetzt erstmal weiter realtech
ich finds heftig krass dass sie sich so
zeigen kann ohne dass das ganze auf
irgendwie +18 gestellt wird ich war
letztens schon leicht verstörend als ich
auf ein video von katja reagiert habe
vor einem halben jahr oder einem jahr
und kiel video war nicht ab 18 aber
meine reaktion war ab 18
aber youtube da sie wieder richtig den
nagel mit dem kopf da drauf das war
total beschissen das sprichwort luca ich
weiß du magst mal ganz kurz haben die
die straße abgesperrt oder fahren da
einfach so autos land stellt euch vor
ihr sitzt mit eurem vater oder mutter
und ihrer schwester im auto wollte in
urlaub fahren und auf einmal läuft der
sonne nackte katja glaser witz über die
straße aber wir sind hier nicht um
katies körpern irgendeiner form zu
bewerten sondern um uns die musik zu
ohren zu führen und damit machen jetzt
mal weiter
zweimal lag sinken
[Musik]
kann ich die szene normal sehen
das ist schon krass
also das dass sicher gestellt wird dass
es schon irre
schau mich an wie dieses mainz mit den
erziehern ja
dann bin ich wohl kein man die schönste
weit und breit doch anstatt in ein
nachweislich in die 1
[Musik]
alter schwede hat jako das leben klar
ich meine müsst euch das einfach mal
vorstellen sie läuft hier nackt
sie hat halt dieses komische servierten
ding da über ihren brustwarzen aber
eigentlich läuft sie mehr oder weniger
nackte bei ihnen eine bundesstraße und
steckt sich die toblerone und reiben und
sagen dass hier im tempel in als was
denken sie diese autofahrer alte hier
tut mir leid
täglich gibt es mehr wie ein magazin du
bist das essen von man
katja dartsch es echt nicht gerade gut
allerdings muss ich ganz ehrlich zugeben
hat ja dieser song ist bisher hammer
also deine stimme raste auf jeden fall
trainiert und vor allem den floh- und
keine ahnung was ich mal ich bin kein
julians blog ich kann jetzt nicht
richtig in die texte analysieren oder so
aber es klingt auf jeden fall mit
lakonischer und melodischer als in der
letzten lieder
glück wurde nicht katja sich verbessert
wunsch ich habe leider jetzt schon
ohrwurm kurzes zwischenfazit sind die
ticker bei der hälfte angekommen
mit zweimal bisher die who gehört einmal
zu beginn und jetzt gerade noch mal was
mich allerdings direkt sehr sehr hart ab
fakt ist das alles ein one take ist
natürlich beides ist amerika okay das
ist eine komplett andere liga kam zu
wenig da war das musikvideo auch ein one
take a es wurde also ohne jeglichen
schritt hochgeladen
dort wurden allerdings choreografien
eingebracht und henze und verschiedene
szenarien dargestellt und bei katja sie
läuft einfach nackt über eine
bundesstraße und da kommt mal ein apfel
einge photoshop und mal so ein paar
texte musik video fand ich bei dicke
lippen und die um einiges besser
[Musik]
diese fahrradfahrer die müssen nicht
autodeck was geht hier ab
[Musik]
diese motorradfahrer sind doch vorhin
auch schon der vorbeigefahren
dieses ganze musik videos einfach so
peinlich das verstehe ich nicht
ich finde dieses low down halbe
geschwindigkeit irgendwie nie so
wirklich gar küche schlafzimmer dann auf
meinen reisen couch ich mach mein mann
nie selbst ich bin keine spielerfrau
das war die erste vernünftige animation
die drin war mit diesem papierflieger
also dass wir hier so reingeflogen kommt
und dann hier wieder raus betreiben zu
du magst kommt ach gott
ist das der von doggy wenigstens hat sie
sollen durchlaufen das element bei dem
musik videos auch wenn das halt dieser
dicke pizzabote ist ich mag es korb und
haar und kein romantisches macht mir
nicht auf meine johnsons bist du hier
gleich handeln
das ist schon crazy also der komplette
text besteht einfach nur aus
zweideutigkeiten wie ich machte eine
kanone hart oder mache ich nicht auf
manager sonst nicht so angeleint und
keine ahnung was und das zieht sich
durch jeden song von ihr also katja ich
fänd's schon cool wenn du mal ab und zu
vielleicht im nächsten lied so eine
gewisse message mit rein bringst was ich
mir halt real-tor ganz gut vorstellen
könnte
das wird dann allerdings wahrscheinlich
nicht so gut verkaufen bei dem image
wäre wenn katja das ganze so ein
bisschen ernster darstellt wie sie
selbst eigentlich rüberkommen und dass
sie eigentlich nur eine rolle spielt und
das ganze dann irgendwie ein bisschen
self des mäßig macht und keine ahnung
was war das was sie jetzt macht ist
naja sie stellt sich halt als püppchen
da die nutzung der geschlechtsakt da ist
und ja ich denke sie will auch so
dargestellt werden also wir hören ja
weiter das ist ja nicht mehr zu toppen
was da ankommt
ich breche das an der stelle ab ich
meine schaut euch das an diese szene
hier
sie läuft da hatte hier sie läuft mit
einem etwas korpulenten mann an der
leine über eine bundesstraße die nicht
abgesperrte zu diesem video drehen
sondern dann auch autos her fahren und
der hier kommt gerade aus dem urlaub
oder fährt gerade in den urlaub alter
sondern schlaf dingen oben mit dabei ist
und was denkt sich katja glaser wird es
dabei ich frag mich einfach warum dann
nicht mal der staat ankommt und so sagt
hey du läufst auf irgendeiner straße
lange das ist überhaupt nicht
regelkonformen das wahrscheinlich nicht
eine drehgenehmigung und das ist vor
allem auch noch erregung öffentlichen
ärgernisses aber komme ich tue mir die
letzten sekunden auch noch an zufall
sein der beat rock gut
ja das war schon ein schock dieser das
ist ja echt crazy andere autofahrer
müssen hier irgendwie ausweichen und
abbremsen weil wieder halb nackt mit
ihrem dicke freunde über die straße
läuft
[Musik]
also ich glaube dieses bild beschreibt
einig das komplette video einfach nur
peinlich
das war es allerdings jetzt auch mit
meiner reaktion auf den song von katja
er hat 34.000 likes gerade und 7000
dislike also na ja es geht deutsche
youtuber musik ist für mich halt einfach
schon gut bei der community angekommen
wenn es mehr likes des lecks hat also
katja du hast an der stelle guten job
gemacht bei den letzten beiden songs von
katja also bei body und dicke lippen
habe ich immer gesagt ok hat ja
musikalisch geht da echt noch einiges
mehr also da sehe ich auf jeden fall
entwicklungspotenzial und musikvideos
auch schon okay doch diesmal muss ich
sagen es ist der krasseste ohrwurm den
ich bisher hatte von den liedern das
musikvideo ist allerdings komplette
scheiße
ach du scheiße und müssen zum flughafen
jude unser flug in einer stunde als
erstes fragen warum nicht nach leipzig
aber in salzburg fahren bzw frieden
gewinnen
das heilige land
wir sind gelandet in leipzig unser
finales ziel ist allerdings nicht leicht
sich sondern verbirgt das ist nochmals
zwei stunden von leipzig entfernt ja
sind wir weil wir dort auf einem
festival sind
das ist die waren sie gerade rola maxian
acker julio ich und wir vor allem ich
hatte nur zwei stunden
welcher ja gar nicht mitgerechnet eis
meldet im hotel angekommen einem mädchen
das ist allen jan sollten hotelzimmer
leute ist es mittlerweile halb eins ich
laufe hier allein durch plauen wo wir
hier untergebracht sind
[Musik]
ebenfalls sieht hier echt alles sehr
sehr schön aus das muss sich dieser
stadt lassen
also wir sind hier halt irgendwie
untergebracht weil das der nächste ort
am festival ist es ist echt am arsch der
welt aber schöne gebäude auf jeden fall
bblz hunger und du kannst noch ein
mcdonald and oben im hotelzimmer ich hab
grad noch mal bio beschritten und die
anderen sind beim festival
aber das kann ich mir nicht mehr antun
wenn man halt noch ein bisschen am arsch
ist ja ich hoffe einfach irgendwas zu
essen in dieser stadt halt echt alt wird
bereits kein mensch wo mein gürtel leute
mein morgens gerettet ist nicht bezahlt
von mcdonald's
das ist einzige was hier noch irgendwie
auf hat ich hab nen schönen fleck wenige
hergeholt freunde ich habe auch noch
nicht mit glas bekommen gleis zu hause
täglich über neues flaschen ich bin ja
auch ne flasche also passt das relativ
gute mitarbeiter vorne wollte dann noch
ein autogramm haben wir auch mega nett
der typ und er dann erst mal gesagt hey
du bist ja ganz schön weit weg von zu
hause und jetzt erst mal aufgefallen ich
bin genau am anderen ende von
deutschland wir sind quasi direkt an der
grenze zu tschechien
und wenn ich in köln bin bin ich halt
direkt an der grenze zu holland also
komplett andere seiten aber ich gehe mal
nach außen ist das erst mal gar nicht
mehr sogar den heutigen tag ist auch
bernd meine damen und herren
bei mir hat er schon gemerkt dass
meisten was in diesem blog gemacht habe
ist eigentlich auf ktm reagiert weil er
halt heute raus gekommen ist und ich
darauf reagieren wollte allerdings bin
ich halt auch nach leipzig geflogen
in saalburg oder klauen sind wirklich
weiß ich fürchte schneidet auch den
blogs ende den ekz und das gleicht es
euch gefallen hat umschreibt man werde
die kommentare was machen und
weltfrieden
[Musik]